ahora vamos a pensar en cómo procesa
nuestro cuerpo la azúcar y explorar las
posibilidades de que tuviéramos diabetes
te pido que tomen las cosas con cuidado
porque yo no soy un doctor no daremos
consejos médicos y más bien el objetivo
es explorar cómo funcionan las cosas y
tratar de entenderlo ahora veamos qué
pasa cuando tomo un alimento voy a
dibujar el eje horizontal y le voy a
llamar horas y en el eje vertical vamos
a poner en la concentración de azúcar en
nuestra sangre o sea la concentración de
azúcar en la sangre a esto se le llama
glucosa si la azúcar en la sangre se
llama glucosa pero aquí vamos a poner la
concentración si recuerda estamos
hablando de glucosa y la concentración
y ahora aquí voy a poner un 50 en
nuestras unidades son miligramos por
decilitro bueno mejor lo pongo de esta
manera todo lo que pongamos en este eje
serán miligramos por decilitro y en otro
vídeo vamos a ver cómo podemos pensar
esta cantidad en términos más
coloquiales
entonces aquí voy a poner el 50 aquí voy
a poner el 100 aquí sería el 150 y más
acá 200
y ahora vamos a pensar qué pasaría en
una persona normal así que voy a poner
aquí las horas voy a poner la 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 y 8
entonces para una persona que no ha
consumido alimentos al menos por 8 horas
o sea su nivel de azúcar en ayunas es de
80 miligramos por decilitro
y entonces vamos a ponerlo aquí este es
el de una persona normal que son más o
menos 80 miligramos que tiene que verse
pues como esto
normalmente pensamos en esto en términos
del ayuno o sea tal vez esta hora 1 sean
las 7 de la mañana y entonces es el
nivel a las 7 de la mañana
y si hacemos referencia a los términos
que utilizan los doctores si los
doctores a esto que está aquí le llaman
preparan dial si preparan dial
y bueno esta palabra tan rimbombante
este que solo se refiere a antes de
tomar alimentos el pre se refiere antes
y antes de tomar alimentos
si lo pensábamos después de tomar
alimentos sería postprandial pero bueno
este es preparan dial y ahora digamos
que en la hora número 2 esta persona va
a tomar el desayuno entonces normalmente
en el desayuno pues bien en
carbohidratos y al consumirlos se van a
transformar en glucosa entonces el nivel
de glucosa en la sangre se va a
incrementar en más o menos hay algunos
picos de cada 45 minutos cuando se están
tomando alimentos entonces este
incremento se da aquí están más o menos
los 45 minutos y en un individuo normal
el nivel de glucosa no debe de rebasar
los 120 miligramos por decilitro bueno
habrá algunas excepciones aquí estamos
hablando en términos generales de una
persona normal un desayuno normal y
bueno no vas a tomar un litro de miel o
hacer cosas locas y entonces el 120 pues
anda más o menos por aquí bueno una
persona diabética
obviamente estaría arriba de este este
nivel y más o menos un par de horas
después este nivel tiene que reducir y
diríamos que podría estar por ahí de los
100 miligramos por decilitro
y después tal vez en un término de otras
dos horas después podríamos pensar que
el nivel regresó al nivel normal el de
los 80 en miligramos por decilitro bueno
y esto es a lo que le llamamos normal
bueno tampoco te asustes y un día base
por la mañana a tomar un un análisis de
sangre y resultado 85 odio
no pasa nada es decir puede haber
algunas fluctuaciones ligeras alrededor
del del rango normal eso puede pasar
entre una persona y otra persona ahora
es si una persona tiene diabetes y
entonces no tiene suficiente insulina o
su cuerpo está de sensibilizado a la
insulina entonces el nivel de glucosa va
a incrementar así que un día puedes
hacer una medición utilizando estos
monitores de glucosa que venden en las
farmacias y entonces ese día te levantas
vas a tomar una muestra de sangre de tu
dedo y digamos que
llega por aquí al 140 bueno pues lo
primero que debes de hacer es no
asustarte
tal vez repetir la medición y bueno
definitivamente sería buena idea
consultar a un médico te recuerdo aquí
no estamos dando consejos médicos se
trata de entender cómo funcionan estas
cosas no se trata de que cambies tus
hábitos en base a lo que yo estoy
diciendo pero en el caso en que esta
fuera una medición este pues si
podríamos estar pensando que si tu
cuerpo no fue capaz de reducir la
glucosa en un periodo de 8 horas es
decir que la insulina permitiera el
ingreso de la glucosa
y que estuviera en sus niveles normales
entonces tal vez si sería buena idea
preocuparse un poco bueno hay un umbral
y un rango en dentro del cual pueden
estar estas mediciones pero insisto es
decir tus niveles de medición las
existen hay unas ojo no después de haber
tomado alimentos sino en ayunas y
digamos que estás cercano a este umbral
del 130 más o menos por aquí entonces si
sería buena idea consultar a un médico y
ver la probabilidad de que uno tenga
diabetes y esto sería de preocuparse y
también en el caso en el que uno tome
alimentos bueno puede dispararse hasta
180 pero lo que estamos viendo aquí es
el umbral en el cual nos podría llamar
la atención de que nuestro cuerpo no
está procesando bien la azúcar esto que
estoy dibujando aquí es el 180 y bueno
es un es un pequeño rango también por
otro lado no pienses que si la medición
dio 124 no tienes diabetes
225 si la tienes no la idea es
establecer un umbral tener un punto de
referencia y si después de tomar
alimentos tu nivel de azúcar se
disparará hasta el 200 s sería también
un motivo para preocuparse entonces una
persona que tiene diabetes más o menos
un nivel de glucosa se observaría así
está empezando a ir por el 120 cuando
toma un alimento obviamente se
incrementaría se dispararía bueno tiene
que procesar una cierta cantidad de
glucosa si no la procesará bueno pues
moriría no se está procesando de manera
correcta la glucosa claro empieza a
disminuir no tanto como para llegar a
los niveles normales pero se metaboliza
y llega a este nivel más o menos otra
vez es de 120 125 que puede ser motivo
de preocupación
y en general bueno yo he visto que si
uno está en el umbral más o menos del
100 bueno tal vez sería buena idea
pensar en modificar algunos hábitos algo
relacionado con el estilo de vida y si
se dispara al 120 130 bueno es probable
que tengas una tendencia o probabilidad
de tener diabetes
esto que está aquí lo consideramos alto
y si una persona tiene este
comportamiento es probable que sea
diabético si una persona tiene estos
niveles de azúcar y recuerda yo no soy
un doctor y estos no son consejos
médicos simplemente estamos tratando de
entender cómo funciona